are we getting closer to objective
reality
how do we know
if these interfaces in the process of
science
the reason we like those interfaces is
because they're predictive of some
aspects strongly predictive about some
aspects of our reality
is that completely deviating from
our understanding of that reality or is
it helping us get closer and closer and
closer
well of course one critical constraint
on all of our theories is that they are
empirically tested and past
the experiments that we
have for them so so no one's arguing
against experiments being important and
wanting to test all of our our current
theories
and uh any new theories on that so
that's that's
that's all there
but
we have good reason to believe
that science will never get a theory of
everything
everything everything everything
everything right a final theory of
everything right
i think that my own take is for what
it's worth is that girdles in
completeness theorem
sort of points us in that direction that
even with mathematics uh any finite
accidentization that's sophisticated
enough to be able to do arithmetic
it's easy to show that there'll be
statements that are true that can't be
proven
can't be deduced from within that
framework and if you add the new
statements to your axioms then there'll
be always new statements that are true
but can't be proven with a new axiom
system
and
the best scientific theories um
indian physics for example and also now
evolution are mathematical so our
theories are going to be they're going
to have their own assumptions
and
they'll be mathematically precise and
they'll be theories perhaps of
everything except those assumptions
because the assumptions are
we say please grant me these assumptions
if you grant me these assumptions then i
can explain this other stuff
but so you have the assumptions that um
[Music]
are
like miracles as far as the theory is
concerned they're not explained they're
the starting points for explanation and
then you have the mathematical structure
of the theory itself which will have the
girdle limits
and so
my my take is that um reality whatever
it is is
always going to transcend
any
conceptual theory that we can come up
with
you